come get your birthday present we're
talking apex legends specifically
lifeline the combat medic Jake what's
the rundown on this character lifeline
is support heal character she has a heal
drone she's got some really cool passive
abilities for called combat medic and
she has an ultimate that can basically
equip your team if used properly and I
think the number one take away with
lifeline is that your team should be
feeding your ultimate accelerants to
lifeline and she should just be calling
in those care package as much as much as
possible because you can get some really
good drops off that you can't get any
weapons but you can get level 3 armor
and get the digital threat yeah so yeah
that I think that's the number one
takeaway yeah I definitely like those
ultimate accelerants that are scattered
across the map whenever I see one if I
have a lifeline on my team I am calling
it out and giving it to her yeah the
care package is interesting because at
some point in the game or in a match you
don't necessarily want to call that down
right
it will give away your position if
you're you know say you have everything
you need in the squad that being said
can you speak on like the later stages
like when the circle is getting tight
there's other uses with that
yeah I've found that when you get later
into the round and especially if you're
stuck in an area with no cover throwing
that down can also serve as some cover
for your team totally
obviously the team's gonna know exactly
where you are but hey that could protect
you from gunfire from pretty much any
direction if you are able to follow it
yeah the other thing about her care
package I found interesting was that
lifelines care packages are white and
blue whereas the natural air drops in
the game are white and red so if you're
scavenging cross the land and you see a
a white and blue care package that's not
yours chances are there's an enemy life
line nearby which is a good call-out I
think yeah they also won't show up on
your mini-map so those little blue
circles that show up those are for the
naturally occurring care packages but
hers will not so if you see one dropping
and you don't see that marker on your
map it's probably another team lets rein
it back to her tactical which is doc the
heal drone what can you say about the
hill drop
I mean that's pretty much what it is you
throw it down I think it's got about a
minute cooldown and it heals your
teammates for a set amount of time as
long as they're close to it it also
heals enemies which is an interesting
thing you found out right so as much as
you'd like to throw down the gila drone
there's a time for it right so not
necessarily when you're you know under
fire in the thick of it with enemies
right next to you but if you have found
a nice shooting spot and your team has
kind of posts it up and are attacking as
a support character does you want to
like lay that right behind your team and
to call it out definitely I think the
last thing with the heal drone too is
that if you have a downed teammate throw
that thing before you revive them so the
second they are revived they can be
getting that health up next her passive
the combat medic I think it's my
favorite passive in the game yeah
totally healing items at shield shield
batteries syringes med kits Phoenix kits
are 25% faster that's big overall faster
revive and you throw down a shield in
front of you and this shield is pretty
much indestructible right I can't get
grenades through it you can't get
bullets through it obviously if you come
at her from a different angle you can
shoot it or I think if you lob a grenade
over there's a chance that could hit her
right it's pretty impenetrable if you
know how to line that up
totally which plays in the fact that you
want to be conscious of where you're
putting it you know you want to be
forward fronting against incoming fire
because that's where that shields gonna
draw an aggressive healing with her
isn't isn't a bad idea
I wouldn't do it all the time but
because of that shield if you're in a
firefight and you see a downed teammate
if you can make it to them and start
healing you'll be safe while you're
doing that well those are her three main
abilities any final thoughts Jake you
have one thing I would say is that I
think you can play her well typically
you probably want to stay behind your
team and offer support you can't play
her kind of aggressively just because of
how quickly she can heal herself with
syringes and shield cells and whatnot so
a lot of times I found myself flanking
and I was able to do a lot of damage
that way because I could fire a couple
rounds maybe knock someone and then run
back and use a bunch of shield cells to
heal and just
doing that while my well the rest of my
team was focusing fire or you know
supplying cover fire for me yeah
definitely the last thing I sought I
found kind of interesting was the gold
helmet which the perk on that regens
tactical and ultimate abilities bar
quicker if you have one you could kind
of be a cool teammate and give it to a
lifeline so she can drop her care
packages quicker you could do that I
just thought that was interesting I'll
do that from now for sure well thank you
Jake and thank you guys for watching we
have more apex Legends guides coming
down the road so stay tuned the game
spot
[Music]